yes we've had the latest figures for GDP
economic output how the economy is doing
from the office for National statistics
this morning these are the monthly
figures for December and crucially for
those keeping the UK's economic
scorecard the quarterly figures for the
end of last year and while growth
contracted the economy shrank in
December by half a percent strikes and
snow contributing to a very difficult
month across the board in the economy
the quarterly figure showed flat growth
zero growth didn't grow it didn't shrink
and that means the UK has on the
technical definition avoided a recession
a recession is two consecutive quarters
of economic contraction the economy
getting smaller while it shrank in the
third quarter of 2022 it was flat in the
final quarter of the year so the UK
isn't yet in recession but there is not
a lot of good economic news here facing
huge challenges across the board the
chancellor with public sector strikes
still raging his own party calling for
tax cuts business desperate for
incentives to start investing money in
the UK I'll be talking to him in the
next hour to hear what he plans to do
about it